this video is a summary video on
l-carnitine what is it and what's the
most important use of l-carnitine
it's an amino acid that transports fat
into the mitochondria the mitochondria
is the energy Factory in all of your
cells it produces the energy currency
called ATP and l-carnitine also will
handle some of the waste that's
generated from the fat that's being
oxidized now since its job is to
transport fat into the oven sort of
speak for burning people take it to lose
weight okay they take it to develop more
energy while they're working out they
get more endurance they have better
recovery if they're exercising so these
are the main reasons why people consume
this but there's actually a bigger
reason that I'm going to talk about most
of your cells okay contain between 500
and 2,000 mitochondria but the heart
cell has 5,000 mitochondria that's
incredible that's a lot of mitochondria
now the interesting thing about the
heart muscle that's different than the
skeletal muscle is it doesn't have a
glycogen reserve and when you burn fat
most of that fat turns into free fatty
acids and only 40 percent of it turns
into ketones so when we talk about fat
burning we're not talking about just
ketones we're also talking about fatty
acids and the heart loves fatty acids in
fact it runs in fatty acids it runs on
other things like lactate and ketones
but it loves fatty acids so it needs
l-carnitine to transport these fatty
acids into the machinery to burn for its
energy so if you have a congestive heart
failure or you have some arrhythmia
problem with the heart or any type of
heart damage this product is what you
would want to consume in addition to
coenzyme q-10 those two are dynamite for
the heart as they age they make less and
less
carnitine and also as they age they
cannot digest or absorb protein as well
so protein does not turn into body
tissue like it did when they were 18
years old not to mention the fact that a
lot of people have lost stomach acids so
they're not digesting this protein to
eventually get this as well because your
body makes it so we have a protein
absorption problem we have a digestive
problem being able to break down the
protein as we age we can't make this as
well and also if you're not consuming
the cofactors to make it like b6 vitamin
C some of the other B vitamins and that
could be another reason why this could
benefit you but I just wanted to create
this summary video to point out that L
carnitine is not just for athletes okay
not just for people that want to lose
weight it's also and even more
importantly for people that want to
support a healthy cardiovascular system
thanks for watching if you're liking
this content please subscribe now and I
will actually keep you updated on future
videos